yo where would you say like uh for you
obviously the the podcast helps water
everything because it's so massive
um do you feel like being you guys are
on camera a lot every week sometimes two
episodes a week always one two and a
patreon sometimes one on a patreon but
at least two sometimes three it's a lot
of time right yeah so yeah do you ever
feel like uh is it does it does it take
away from the comedy because it's so
it's it's so much bandwidth towards that
or do you feel like they kind of like
one hand washes the other you you have
one hand watch the other but the
struggle being married and trying to be
a good husband of course I'll lamp
Sunday from his weekend of doing shows
we'll have a call about Monday's episode
month so I prep for that when I get home
spend like an hour of my wife prep for
the episode Monday the episode Tuesday
and spend all the time my wife hopefully
Monday night Tuesday we got two episodes
on the next day sometimes so I'll do
that or I'm doing like voice over for a
Hulu show or a Netflix show so I'll do
both of those or you know just yeah then
Wednesday two episodes then Thursday I'm
out of town on for shows Thursday Friday
Saturday damn how long's your marriage
going to last with all that that's the
thing I don't want to be the guy I want
to be the greatest comic ever but I
don't want to be the greatest comic ever
alone that's the saddest [ __ ] in the
world to me is these guys who are all
the way up not the saddest but I don't
think it's worth it yeah you see guys
like I mean not even to say names but
you see guys who get divorced and
they're like yeah you're that
[ __ ] but you're also kind of you
know you're hanging out with me until
three in the morning you're 54 years old
go home man yeah you're going home alone
and you don't want to do that and that's
not I'm not picking on people but I
always said I can't ha I have to have
both and I can't give up my wife right I
mean I think with anything they're
sacrificed so as long as she's like
knows what's up she kind of knows she
knows herself but you're also gonna you
got kids if I want kids I don't want
kids to necessarily know what's up yeah
that's my dad he got to go do his thing
but yeah he's not any of my baseball
games no that's real man I mean you miss
[ __ ] bro like I mean I I mean as busy
even as busy as I am like and I try to
make sure that I'm there as much as I
can be but just sometimes you just gotta
you're gonna miss some [ __ ] but I need
to make he needs to feel like my dad is
there when I need him my dad is there
for a lot of [ __ ] if not ever yeah and
eventually you're gonna get to the point
where you're printing money and you know
you could just take a private jet to
make the soccer game that's the one I'm
hoping yeah I am hoping like at a
certain point is there's a lot more time
for family and a little less uh a little
less busy